you know I hate to say I Told You So
when my friends and I left California
three years ago we told you the state
was dying and now even California
officials are admitting we were right
after More Than A Century of long-term
population growth the state of
California is now officially predicted
to stagnate California today has about
39 and a quarter million people a decade
ago that number was predicted to grow to
53 million by 2060. just three years ago
that prediction was adjusted down
significantly to 45 million and last
week the California Department of
Finance adjusted the prediction down
once more to 39 and a quarter million
the same number that we have today
which means that if the trend of
prediction adjustments keeps up it's
likely that California will die not of
mere stagnation but of mass Exodus and
California is not the only liberal State
losing people New York is facing the
exact same problem as the state's
comptroller grudgingly just admitted on
TV
in terms of our budget planning process
in New York we have the somewhat strange
calendar of the fiscal year starts on
April 1st and of course you don't have
your heart a tax collection date until
April 15th so the budget that was put in
place you know frankly was based on more
optimistic numbers but you know in The
Current financial plan uh division of
budget has taken down each year for the
next uh for the next few years five
billion dollars in revenue and and you
know we're now uh slightly ahead of
current updated projections which have
been lowered but the weakness Neil has
been in the personal income tax
Collections and some of that has to do
with taxpayer migration that you alluded
to but I I think as much of it's just
reflective of of a slowing economy right
now did you catch that did you catch
that explanation forget about tax
revenue and New York or whatever just as
a matter of politics just as a matter of
rhetoric that is what we observers of
rhetoric call an excrement sandwich that
is where you wedge the bad news in
between perfectly fine and ordinary news
oh yes tax receipts are down because of
the bad economy
and the mass Exodus and the bad economy
of course so uh that's no big deal what
was that oh there was uh this was the
bad economy now what what did you say
before that oh I was I was talking about
the bad economy no after what was the
one after that right there in the middle
oh right people are fleeing your state
people are leaving
the liberal states
forget about the consequences of what
that means for the red States forget for
a moment about what that means for
National Unity or whatever we can get to
that later just take a moment to savor
at least one consolation of being a
conservative which is that eventually
after a long time perhaps
consequences catch up with bad
government eventually after a long time
might take decades reality reasserts
itself in the end as it is reasserting
itself in New York and California today
I'm Michael knowlesis the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the Michael Knowles show
wonderful to be with you as always in
just a moment we have a middle-aged
white guy from the Civil Air Patrol
talking about how terrible middle-aged
white guys are and sending a message to
any white guy who might want to join the
military or any form of national service
we'll get to that in a second first
though I want to zoom out
internationally because this collapse of
liberal policies and this reflection in
public opinion polls and people's
behavior it's not just happening in the
states it's not just happening in New
York and California this is a global
issue you know this week I'm on the road
I'm in Hungary very very excited I mean
I'm not literally in Hungary right now
I'll be flying out to Hungary almost
immediately after this show and I'll be
giving a speech outside of Budapest on
Friday so if you're in town happen to be
in the neighborhood go check that out at
MCC Fest I've got my new book it's the
Hungarian translation of my first blank
book reasons to vote for Democrats a
comprehensive guy that is now available
in Hungary starting today but
it's not just Hungary that's gone pretty
conservative
this is a global issue it's taking over
the West Spain right now is looking at
its first properly right-wing government
since Francisco Franco in 1975 I alluded
to this last week well the numbers are
becoming even clearer
polls are showing that the conservative
popular party which is the sort of
center-right mainstream
regular old kind of squishy Republican
party equivalent in Spain led by Alberto
Nunez feijo sure I'm mispronouncing that
a has enough support to unseat the
Socialist prime minister Pedro Sanchez
but doesn't have enough support to get
an outright majority which means that
the kind of center-right conservative
ish party is going to have a form of
coalition government with a properly
conservative party which is the Box
party means voice that is a nationalist
party it's anti-immigration it's
anti-feminist it's anti-liberal it's an
actual conservative party so with the
properly conservative party is the king
maker for the first time in now 50 years
or so you're going to see
potentially
we'll get to why I say potentially in a
second a properly right-wing government
in Spain
what is the leader of that party saying
saying neither globalist agendas nor a
separatists concessions can prevent
access to water for all this issue of
water this issue of environmentalist
policy this has become a major major
issue in Spain where conservatives where
Ordinary People are seeing the Liberals
and the squishes and the globalists
prioritizing abstract Humanity or even
worse prioritizing
regular old Wildlife or the trees or the
grass or whatever over actual people in
the here and now and the conservative
party comes in this is now rocket
science they come in and they say hey
the Spanish people should have access to
water
did not take a PhD in political science
to see what the conservatives are doing
to win in Spain and in Italy and
elsewhere throughout Europe and in the
United States as well the conservatives
are coming in and they're saying hey you
crazy Pie in the Sky Liberals are
prioritizing all your insane ideologies
over the basic needs and the basic
traditional desires of ordinary people
and after the people have had their
desires and their wishes and their use
of right reason neglected for long
enough they're going to swing back and
they're going to vote for the
conservatives but that's not the whole
story
okay just like how people say oh if you
sleep well you sleep eight hours a night
you get your beauty rest you'll look
you'll look good well that's not the
whole story either when you want to look
really really good you got to check out
geniusell right now head on over to
geniusell.com Knowles our friends over
Virginia sells sold out of their Dark
Spot Corrector and our listeners have
been begging begging like dogs for a
restock well I've got great news it's
back in stock genu sells famous Dark
Spot Corrector has not won but three
Cutting Edge ingredients goes to work
fast Target sunspots dark spots liver
spots even old discoloration on your
face and your hands you can now enjoy
your summer sun Beach and barbecues
without embarrassing spots geniusell's
most popular package also features their
summer Essentials
such as their best-selling Ultra retinol
moisturizer with a powerful retinol
alternative for safe use in the sun
you'll be amazed at how quickly you see
results or 100 of your money back
guaranteed go to geniusell.com
right now get your dark spot corrector
in the geniusell most popular package
that is geniusell.com Knowles right now
save seventy seven zero percent off
geniusell's most popular package all
orders include a mystery luxury gift
while supplies last I love the owner
Coptic Christian from Egypt came over
here for the American dream go to
geniusell.com Knowles
they say that we are potentially seeing
a right-wing response in Europe because
the Liberals still have a lot of power
so you got the Spanish political party
the Vox party calling for a Reconquista
of Spain this is the same kind of
language that was used when the
Spaniards took back Spain from Muslim
Invaders back over 500 years ago they're
saying we need a reconquistan now to
take back Spain from the liberal
globalists who don't care about Spain's
Traditions don't care about Spain's
people and are are flooding Spain
actually with a lot of Muslims like you
saw in in the initial Muslim invasion of
Spain so they're saying we need a
Reconquista to reclaim Spain for what
for what
for the traditional Spanish people okay
good for our cultural practices okay
good for our basic needs and desires of
State correct okay good and
for Christianity because when you talk
in these abstractions what the
traditional culture the traditional
people the traditional practices and
rituals eventually you're going to have
to get a little specific
and the spec the specific answer on all
of those things
the thing that has animated Europe and
the individual European nations in
different ways but all at the same time
is Christianity and so the the properly
conservative parties are not going to be
speaking in the merely math language of
the Enlightenment or rationalism or
human rights or whatever it's going to
be particular it's going to be talking
in terms of Christianity there's a great
line from the Christian writer hillaire
bellock Catholic writer who once
provocatively said the faith is Europe
Europe is the faith
which does not mean that the Christian
faith is reducible to Europe or really
reducible to anything
but it is to say the thing that defines
Europe what we consider to be or what we
consider to be the West it is
Christianity not just in Spain you're
seeing this in Germany as well right now
the right-wing party alternative for
Germany alternative for Deutschland is
climbing to record support a widening
it's laid over all three parties in the
ruling Coalition of Chancellor Olaf
Schultz
the afd
has increased its support to 22 percent
so much like in Spain the only party
that the
seriously right-wing party alternative
for Deutschland is trailing is the
Christian Democrat Party which has 26
percent uh so you could be looking at a
pretty serious right-wing ruling
Coalition there you already saw a
conservative populist Uprising in the
election in Italy
and this is why I say you could have
potentially right-wing governments in
these places because Georgia Maloney was
elected in Italy to be a properly right
wing much more right-wing than we've
seen in the past government and she
hasn't really done that
and this is sometimes what happens
in Europe as in the west broadly you you
get popular support to elect a
right-wing conservative party here we go
baby in the CNN and the media and all
these people they always say it's the
far right extremist fascist nazi the
ultra right-wing
what happens the part
the part they moderate and they run is
basically just a slightly more
conservative version of regular old EU
Brussels Global liberalism that we've
seen for a long time
I'm sorry to say that's basically what
we've seen out of the the Maloney
government so the same thing could
happen in Germany same thing could
happen in Spain or maybe not maybe we're
seeing an actual backlash in Italy some
good news
Italy has come out and banned
[Music]
why do I mention this I mention it
just to underscore this trend that we're
seeing when Trump won in 2016 oh it was
a fluke it was a flu Hillary was
unpopular it was total fluke
it was wrong to pick him as a nominee
because it was but just whatever okay I
guess he won
and then what what about the brexit
remember when brexit happened oh that
was a total fluke it was just because of
some really Savvy marketing campaigns by
the conservatives total fluke though not
indicative of a global Trend okay what
happens when Sweden gets a right-wing
government okay what happens when Italy
gets a right-wing government okay what
happens when the right wing party for
the first time since Francisco Franco
looks like it's going to win in Spain oh
what happens when the right wing party
in Germany looks like it's going what
out how many wins do you need before you
see that the reaction to Global
liberalism is not just some fluke
because Donald Trump is a clever guy on
a debate stage it's a global Trend how
long before the Liberals have to look
themselves in the mirror and say hey did
we screw up hey do people not really
like us anymore
the Smart Ones have done that and
they're clamping down on their power
right now but this is a pattern and it's
it's nice to see with the Italians
because I do hail from the Italian
people on my mother's side
and the Italians despite their
dalliances with socialism and liberalism
the Italians basically
are a right-wing people
the Italians are a little bit they're
it's a mixed bag but they're basically
conservative they haven't had a
functioning government since Octavian
but they're basically
conservative people
now will that be able to win out I think
I think the conservatives have the
numbers in America and all over Europe
can that win out over the way that the
political institutions have been rigged
against conservatives in Brussels in
Washington DC all over
that remains to be seen
clearly the conservatives have taken a
shellacking they undermine Trump's
Administration in routing them out of
office after trying all sorts of failed
kooky attempts to get them at from the
time he was on the campaign Trail
Maloney they seem to have neutered her
government the brexit they weakened the
brexit so it's we can we can say oh I'm
so happy that the the
the people are rising up for
conservatism but it doesn't matter you
have 90 of the people rising up for
conservatism
if they can't grab hold of the political
institutions and wield that power that
a Euro 50 will get you a cup of coffee
the Liberals are taking this populist
threat very seriously
including here including the Democrat
Party
prominent Democrats now are coming out
against RFK Jr
representative Susan Del Bene a Democrat
from Washington who yeah she's just some
random Congress lady but she's also the
head of the Democratic Congressional
Campaign committees this is a major
leadership arm of the Democrat Party she
just came out she called Bobby Kennedy
Junior's covid-19 comments quote
reprehensible she said they're
disqualifying she said such dangerous
racism and hate have no place in America
demonstrate him to be unfit for public
office and must be condemned in the
strongest possible terms good grief lady
what did Bobby Kennedy do he quoted one
scientific study that was published in a
real medical journal saying that kovid
might be harsher on some ethnicities
than others
he quoted scientific literature or
referred to Scientific literature which
cited the threat that bio weapons could
be ethnically targeted
that's all he did in a in a dinner that
was recorded and released
he didn't say anything that was wrong or
even all that controversial
so it's not that the Democrats now are
seeing that Bobby Kennedy made some
comment and they're attacking him for it
they're seeing that Bobby Kennedy is
gaining support among Republicans some
Republicans who like what he said about
covet who liked what he said about for
years now some Independents who were
sick of Biden and Trump and crucially
some Democrats because he's polling at
about 19 of the Democrat Party so
they're seeing that and then they're
jumping on whatever flimsy excuse they
can to attack him to attack him it's not
just her the House minority leader this
is the top Democrat in the house Hakeem
Jeffries whose family
has a long history with racially
provocative statements Hakeem jeffries's
uncle is one of the most infamous
leftist academics in the country who
came up with a whole theory about people
of the Sun and people of the ice and
Africans or the sun people and they're
vibrant and they're wonderful and
they're Lively and white people are the
are the ice people and the ice people
don't have souls and they're basically
animals Nick Cannon the the Entertainer
some years ago came out and echoed these
statements and Hakeem Jeffries has
defended his uncle before and actually
the only way that Professor Jeffries was
finally run out of Academia was was one
time he he went really far in his
attacks on the ice people and he veered
into what is called anti-Semitism such
that he could plausibly have been
accused of attacking a racial minority
back when he was just attacking the
racial majority it was all well and good
but but finally he veered to the point
where they could say okay you're you're
engaging in the same kind of racism that
we say is is verb so they they ran
Jeffries out but no one's really ever
apologized for him they kind of just
brushed him under the rug anyway all of
that is Prelude to say Hakeem Jeffrey
says why would you give Bobby Kennedy Jr
a congressional platform to spew his
hatred
here's the answer
Robert F Kennedy Jr is a living
breathing false flag operation
by the right wing
to undermine the Democrats
living breathing false flag operation
like he was constructed in a lab with
the conservatives this this
could be somewhat plausible if he came
out of nowhere like an Andrew Yang or
like of a vague ramaswamy even if they
were running as Democrats but Bobby
Kennedy Jr is a Kennedy his dad was the
Attorney General of the United States is
his uncle was Jack Kennedy okay this is
the most prominent Democrat family in
America I don't think it's an OP by the
conservatives this is a coordinated
attack right now from Democrat Party
leadership to kill not only populism
that you see on the right but populism
even that's cropping up on the left and
that's because populism breaks that
traditional boundary just the right
versus the left or the Republicans
versus the Democrats that populism comes
in as you saw with Trump in 2016 and
you're going to have a huge number of
Republicans just like all of the
Democrats who were irritated at Trump
and actually you're gonna have some
Democrats who were formerly Democrats
who come over and say this Trump guy I
kind of like what he's saying it breaks
up what is referred to as the uniparty
it it throws a wrench in the political
establishment which is why the
established part powers from both
parties are going to attack the trumps
but the trumps aren't going away because
they're trumps and there are Nigel
farages and there are Victor or bonds
and there are Georgia Malones and there
are Vox parties in Spain and it's
growing because of the dissatisfaction
not just with the ruling party
but with the whole regime throughout the
West
the health of our political structure
not so great when when you're concerned
about your health and you want some
health care options you got to check out
Samaritan Ministries right now go to
samaritanministries.org Knowles how are
you paying for your health care how's it
working out for you
if it's working perfectly great if not
listen closely because I've got a
solution for you a Biblical solution
called Samaritan Ministries Samaritan
Ministries is a community of Christians
paying one another's medical bills it's
affordable health care sharing and
because it's not Insurance there are no
restrictive networks here's how it works
when a medical need arises or you choose
the health care provider that is right
for you and have a say in the treatment
you receive send your medical bills to
Samaritan Ministries they will notify
fellow members to pray for you and send
money directly to you to help you pay
those bills it could be more affordable
than what you're paying right now and if
it's the right fit you can join anytime
even today check it out at
samaritanministries.org Knowles k o w l
e s I know a lot of people are
dissatisfied with the way our health
care System currently works in the
United States well here is a great
alternative to check out that would be
samaritanministries.org
Knowles Canada w-l-e-s
environmentalists
not only Hypocrites totally insufferable
right they tell you
they're riding a bicycle while they're
flying in private jets they'll insist to
you that you stop eating meat because of
methane from sweet little cows but then
they'll happily Chow Down on tasty wagyu
at Davos
I bet you do a better job of conserving
the environment than the likes of John
Kerry or Saint Greta of the Blessed
sailboat especially
if you get Jeremy's new green tea and
citrus hand soap I didn't know where
that was going but it's going to
Jeremy's head it's free of parabens and
sulfates it's also free of Dei and ESG
and LMNOP it's not tested on animals
it's made right here in the USA that
means you can feel patriotic and morally
Superior all at the same time do
yourself a favor wash your hands
of hypocritical leftism once and for all
head on over to jeremy'srazors.com so we
can afford even better copywriters on
this sales pitch go order your green tea
and citrus hand soap today
speaking of middle-aged white dudes
like Bobby Kennedy Jr the Civil Air
Patrol
as a fella I guess some kind of a
spokesman Mark wutan it's gone viral on
tick tock to insist
that national service stop hiring
middle-aged white dudes
there he is stop hiring middle-aged
white people
especially dudes there are pilots
because
honestly we all think alike too much and
if we're going to be preaching diversity
and being inclusive and For Crying Out
Loud Let's back it up with uh you know
let's make the rhetoric meet the reality
we just need to we need to stop
promoting these middle-aged white dudes
we got a middle-aged white dudes they're
the worst I hate them
I hate them and you should too
could you recommend
to a young man in your life in your
family a loved one that they join the
military right now
I know this is the civilian air patrol
so it's like a little a little bit
different
you've seen all the woke stuff out of
the military too could you
this pains me to say I come from a
military family I got my grandfather was
a captain in the United States Navy I've
got Navy and army all throughout my
family line family tree
I've got U.S military veterans going
back to the American Revolution okay it
pains me to say this I am as big a
supporter of the military as there can
possibly be could you knowing that the
chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff is
more concerned with fighting white rage
and indoctrinating
the the cadets and the troops into woke
ideology anti-white ideology anti-male
ideology
could you seriously say ah yes the best
path for you son is to join the military
probably not you might still say it's
it's Noble and right to serve your
country even if you've got a bunch of
complete doofuses running the show
but I don't know it'd be much harder
it would be much harder to recommend
that right now and it's it's not just
the Civil Air Patrol it is all over the
military there's a National Guard
recruiting video
that seemed to be selling more than
recruitment it seemed to be selling
it was an active duty on Army bread and
all I wanted to do growing up was be
part of the military and serve my
country and be part of something bigger
I waited until don't ask don't tell was
repealed so I actually joined when I was
32. my MOS is 12 Alpha I'm an engineer
officer and that means both the
construction type of engineering
building things and making bridges that
also means combat engineering which is
building obstacles destroying obstacles
demolitions all of that fun stuff when I
became an officer infantry and armor
weren't open to females in the combat
side of engineering wasn't open until
about 2016 or so I was drawn to it just
because I like the technical aspect and
again like getting my hands dirty and my
teams have always been very welcoming
it's about what you know it's about
teamwork it's about taking care of your
soldiers so really as long as you show
that you can build trust in your team
and that you take care of your people
gender doesn't matter
if our army believes that gender doesn't
matter
I guess we ought to just pack it in
right we better build some really big
walls around our country because we're
never going to win another War again
because it means that our fighting force
on whom we depend to protect us doesn't
know the most basic aspects of human
nature
of course
the vast majority of people in the Army
in the National Garden throughout the
military they know that this is complete
nonsense
but the leadership the people making the
dazzling recruitment videos the people
calling the shots
even if they don't believe this they're
saying this
gender doesn't matter
and it's considered a positive it
doesn't matter back when I was looking
to join
women do you believe this women weren't
even allowed in combat can you believe
back when I was going to join the
military we were such a backwards nation
that we didn't even send our daughters
to get blown up by jihadis but now we're
much more Progressive we're a much more
virtuous and Progressive nation and
we're going to send our little girls out
there to get hacked up and tortured and
exploded by evil men all around the
world
aren't we so much better now
women in combat that's considered to be
the height of progressivism in this
commercial women in combat is a national
scandal it is a disgrace it is a deep
deep shame and staying on our country
and I don't even hear the conservative
politicians talking about this
women in combat is a very recent
phenomenon as the lady just said in that
commercial
and yet we just totally gave up that
fight
why because we don't want to be seen as
disrespecting women who serve in the
military I have the utmost respect for
women who serve in the military I'm
deeply grateful for their inclination to
serve and sacrifice
but
the military is not about individual
desires
it's not even about individual ability
it's about cohesion and unity and
National policy and who we want to be as
a nation I have no doubt that's that
there are a significant number of women
who would valiantly go out and risk
their lives and bodily Integrity To Go
Fight For America I don't want them to
do that
I think it's bad for America to send
women into Harm's Way I think part of
the reason that we have an army is so
that we don't have to do that
I think it's disordered I think that
women are more nurturing they're the
weaker sex they're the gentler sex and
a major reason to have a military is to
protect them
because boys need their mommies and
husbands need their wives and societies
need a nurturing feminine element and
when we're talking especially when we're
talking about fighting in Lethal Force
we need to not be sentimental and not be
absurdly ideological we need to send out
the toughest strongest brawniest fellas
the reason to keep women out of combat
is as much for the men as for the women
it's as much for the civilians as for
the Fighting Force
and you need to say it even even
moderate Democrats said this 10 years
ago
and now the conservative right wing
won't say it
this is this is a little bit of a
political warning too
things are polarizing pretty quickly
if you haven't learned that in the last
seven years you're probably not going to
learn it the political winners the
politicians who win the political
movements that win are going to be the
ones that are bold they're not going to
be the ones that pussyfoot around every
single little issue and they say well
actually you know look I'm all for
certain radical sexual ideologies but
only starting at age 18 not at age 17.
okay maybe starting at age eight but not
at age seven okay listen I'm for women
getting blown up in combat but I'm not
for them joining the Navy SEALS or
whatever I don't know you're not going
to have a middle ground here on a lot of
these issues the voices that are going
to be rewarded are going to be the Bold
voices who are offering a genuine
alternative this has always been the
best Insight of American conservatism
and it comes from people like Phyllis
Schlafly who this woman who
single-handedly killed the radical
feminist Equal Rights Amendment in the
late 20th century
she called for a choice not an echo
if the libs if the conservatives rather
are just going to be lib light if
they're just going to be squishes if
they're just going to order a slightly
more efficient version of democrat
policies but you know with lower taxes
or something
not only is that not going to help the
country and the society they're not even
going to win elections because people
are just going to vote for the Democrats
I've made this point with the problems
of the DeSantis campaign right now if
the DeSantis campaign is just running is
the better version of Donald Trump it's
going to lose because even if people in
a blind taste test prefer New Coke as
the focus testers at the Coca-Cola
Corporation discovered back when they
reinvented the recipe when people take
that blindfold off and they hear that
they're getting something new they're
not going to like it they're going to
want the OG okay
so you have to offer people a choice not
an echo now speaking of women's issues
we've got to get to our weird sex stuff
segment it wouldn't it wouldn't be a
Michael and all show if we didn't get to
at least one segment on weird sex stuff
it it pervades and defines our culture
in many ways this is from TechCrunch as
AI porn generators get better the stakes
get higher
porn generators have improved while the
ethics around them become stickier
as generative AI enters the mainstream
so too does AI generated porn and like
it's more respectable sibling it's
improving what does this mean you don't
need to go through the whole article it
means that people are going to be able
to make customized pornography they're
going to be able to make pornography
tailored not only to their own tastes
but even resembling perfectly Ordinary
People movie stars sure and celebrities
sure but even just ordinary people
they're going to be able to say Hey you
know Sally from math class yeah put her
in like a porno and here are the
parameters and using relatively few
inputs very very quickly you're going to
be able to get totally customized porn
and it's a big worry and and ethicists
are having a conversation about this but
they're having the conversation I think
in the wrong way
they're saying oh goodness can you
imagine how awful it would be if you get
deep faked if you get porn made about
you without your consent that's going to
be so horrifying and shameful yes of
course you got to protect people from
having their likeness used in this way
that I'm sure that would be deeply
distressing I'm sure that would be very
terrible especially for young women who
are going to be the victims of this in
99.9 of cases yeah total absolutely
you're not going to solve the problem
just focusing on that you're not going
to solve the problem parsing the the
fair uses of people's publicly posted
images to be plugged into some
artificial intelligence machine that in
a matter of seconds totally privately is
going to be able to create whatever
people's fantasies are instantly you're
you're never going to stop it that way
you got to focus on the other side
because the other victims here are the
users
we talk about we need pity for the drug
addicts well you need you need far more
pity for these people because this
problem of pornography and and various
kinds of sexual disorders and addictions
that's far more pervasive than addiction
to fentanyl or Coke or anything like
that
the the more readily this becomes
available
the more people are going to be
attracted to it I said it last week I
said
ethicists are warning about the future
proliferation of sex robots I said don't
underestimate how sexy the sex robots
are going to be
don't underestimate how tempting this
kind of a sin is going to be when it can
be done in the privacy of your own home
if you're going to see a the kind of
ubiquity for this kind of extremely
creepy stuff that you're already seeing
for internet porn so the the only real
solution here is not going to be some
Middle Ground well you can look at this
kind of porn but not this can you look
at this kind of a deep fake but not this
guy it's not going to be parsing these
minute details the way to stop this is
going to be
a broad attack on porn generally you've
got to attack the supply of all porn
because you're you're not going to be
able to litigate in all of these
instances what kind of porn is is
acceptable and what kind of porn is not
acceptable you you think that the
judicial standard exalted by Justice
Potter Stewart that you can't Define
obscenity you can't Define pornography
but you know when you see it you think
that's a hard legal principle to parse
well think about when you're trying to
distinguish in court between what kind
of disgusting degenerate porn is
technically kind of legal and what kind
technically not totally legal it's
Madness that way lies Madness the way to
stop this
is to attack porn generally which will
reduce the demand for porn which will
make it easier to reduce the
profitability of the supply of porn
which will make it easier to come in
with the cudgel of the state and attack
porn even further we've been so
brainwashed by this idea that politics
is always Downstream of culture which
has some truths to it but
also is not much of a difference in many
ways the distinction between culture and
politics is a distinction without a
difference it forgets that laws exist
for a reason if politics is just always
Downstream of culture I guess we should
get rid of murder laws right because
really you're not going to stop Murder
by passing laws against you've just got
to convince people in their hearts
that's not good to commit murder no we
have laws for a reason and laws are
instructive laws are a teacher and in
the case of porn there's always been a
popular consensus against pornography
so it's Democrats Republicans all
throughout the 90s in the 2000s trying
to pass laws against it radical liberal
judges shut it down well now just as
we're saying with the populist growth in
the United States and in Europe you're
going to see a big move against this too
let's get it right this time crack down
on all the porn or else you and your
daughters and everyone around you is
about to be the star of very naughty
movies because the technology is
advancing very very quickly you know
folks
people write into me a lot they say
Michael how do I write into you and it's
confusing because you'd think in order
to write intimate well there's a
specific place to send your questions
that would be the mailbag how do you get
to the mailbag very simple you head on
over to dailywire.com
you go to the Michael Knowles show page
and you click on the mailbag link you
then will have an email popped up for
you and you can attach a file well you
can record that audio file on your phone
you can record it on your laptop you can
record it on your tablet you just attach
that file into the mailbag
email and you click Send right there
through the website it's very very
simple try to keep your mailbag
questions to a minute or less so that I
can use them on the show sometimes
people
you know you it's like you're recording
your Memoir audiobook and then there's
sometimes they're interesting but I
can't I can't use it on the show so send
that in we'll get to it on Friday
speaking of techno dystopia
I got the Jitterbug boom boom I got the
Judo bug is that Wham I think that's
George Mike is that George Michael I
don't really remember but anyway I'll
soon be able to remember because George
Michael might go on tour again seven
years after he died
how is he going to do that you ask well
through Holograms
already the band members in Wham
Shirley Kemp George Michael's best
friend in Wham suggested the idea and
this was backed by fellow backing singer
Helen Pepsi demok croquette
who is also up for this
there's precedent for it it's not just a
fantasy Abba did this last year you know
Abba like Mamma Mia here I go again Abba
did their first gig in 42 years how'd
they do it in hologram form at London's
Queen Elizabeth Olympic Park they
referred to this group of performers not
just as Abba but as avatars
get it
avatars
and it showed them as they looked in
1979.
on the one hand I don't want to seem
like a total Doom and Gloom Luddite even
though I am kind of a Luddite and I
don't love most forms of technology but
I don't want to seem like all
technological advancement is bad it's
not in a way this is just the latest
advance of a multimedia landscape okay
we used to be able to watch movies in
the theater then we could watch movies
at home then we could watch little
glittery images on our pocket and now we
can see them in 3D in space and they can
perform okay fine I think there's
something deeper here
I think this speaks to our culture's
unwillingness to accept death
everybody's got to be eternally Young
nobody can ever die Kanye West had a
hologram of Kim Kardashian's father
recite some words that I guess he had
written for it at Kim Kardashian's
birthday party and I thought man this is
really I would not like this as a
birthday present
because you miss your loved ones who
have gone and so it can be really sweet
in a way it can be really nice and
satisfying to see them again but it's
not
real they're dead they're really dead
we're all gonna die Peter Cushing is
dead I know he's the the fairly recent
Star Wars but he's dead and it's weird
to just not let people die Steve Jobs
gave that famous speech at the Stanford
commencement it was one of the best
commencement addresses in recent memory
on how
death is one of the most important parts
of life
remembering that I'll be dead soon is
the most important tool I've ever
encountered to help me make the big
choices in life
because almost everything
all external expectations all Pride all
fear of embarrassment or failure these
things just fall away in the face of
death
leaving only what is truly important
remembering that you are going to die is
the best way I know to avoid the Trap of
thinking you have something to lose you
are already naked there is no reason not
to follow your heart your time is
limited so don't waste it living someone
else's life
don't be trapped by Dogma which is
living with the results of other
people's thinking
don't let the noise of others opinions
drowned out your own inner voice and
most important have the courage to
follow your heart and intuition they
somehow already know what you truly want
to become
everything else is secondary
the whole speech is quite good
that first part is the key
death is one of the most important
things I've ever seen in life death
gives meaning to your life death gives
narrative structure to your life
it's got a beginning a middle and an end
death concentrates the mind there's a
famous saying of Dr Johnson
which I I sometimes quote as proving the
medicinal benefits of capital punishment
which is depend upon it sir when a man
knows he's to be hanged in a fortnight
it concentrates his mind wonderfully
well we're all going to be hanged in a
fortnight in a certain way we're all
going to die no one here Gets Out Alive
even if we have Holograms all around us
even if we keep putting Peter Cushing in
movies we are going to die
and the sooner you recognize that the
better because it's going to wake you up
and get your life in order and force
certain questions on you is this it do
we just take a dirt nap and turn to worm
food or is there more to life is there
more in Heaven and Earth than is dreamed
of in our philosophies is am I just my
body am I also my soul well if I am a
soul what is the meat what happens to
the soul after death is there more to
the story even for my body
is there a moral order
could I be punished is there Justice
eternally is there such a thing as
eternity you have to face these
questions when you look at death which
is why our liberal culture which is why
the principalities and powers of this
world and spiritual wickedness in high
places
wants to distract you from death
and has broadly succeeded in Modern Life
we don't see death a lot
when our grandparents are going to die
they go away to Little Homes and we
don't see they go to hospice places we
don't have to see it in our own homes
when when people die now you don't
really go to funerals as much you go to
celebrations of life
so-called you don't even usually see a
body or even a casket you just it's
later it's no big deal we just kind of
chew it away
and because modernity has succeeded at
greatly extending people's lives
and they usually they just die when
they're very very old they're kind of
out of the way we don't pay attention to
that anymore that's
some ways more pleasant because death is
deeply unpleasant
when Christ himself when his when his
friend Lazarus died he Weeps
shortest verse in the Bible Jesus wept
but
then we lose focus and then we forget
what we're doing before I go I I meant
to get to this a few days ago Tony
Bennett died Tony Bennett uh I love Tony
Bennett was listening to Tony Bennett
the other day while I was making fresh
pasta with my son uh he's great he's
wonderful and the reason why it's so
particularly sad that he died I mean
look he lived a good long life 96 years
old cut down in his prime flipped his
Corvette that's it no that's not how he
went he died after a battle with
Alzheimer's disease and even for five
years after his Alzheimer's diagnosis he
continued to tour the guy was just a
total inspiration the reason it's so sad
that he died is he's the last of his
kind
because he's he's younger than the other
guys you think of Sinatra Dean Martin
Sinatra was born in 1915 Dean Martin was
born in 1917. uh Tony Bennett was born
in 1926 so Sinatra for Bennett's whole
career referred to Tony Bennett as the
kid
up until Sinatra's Dying Day called him
the kid even though Bennett was a pretty
old man at that point
and so that generation of music that
crooning that that dignified sensibility
that was at least dignified in public if
not always in private comportment for
for some of people of that generation
that's gone now
now public comportment for our popular
musicians is absolutely disgusting and
the lyrics are disgusting and the way
they jiggle around us and but Tony
Bennett and Sinatra and all those guys
they had class they'd put on a jacket in
Italian they would sing and they would
sing in a way that was really delightful
and edifying so anyway R.I.P to Tony
Bennett and a reminder by the way I know
some people say they don't they don't
pray for the dead because it contradicts
their religious views if you've ever
said R.I.P you have prayed for the dead
because your R.I.P means may he rest in
peace Rick with Scott and Pache so
Requiem Scott and Pache Tony Bennett
great guy provided us a lot of great
stuff over the years and I don't look
forward to seeing his hologram but I do
look forward to playing more of his
music
November block this week folks because
I'm on the road in Hungary and
I don't know I've got to go gallivant
around Budapest you know and be part of
the right-wing conspiracy out there so
anyway we'll look forward to a member
block next week become a member in the
meantime use code Knowles Canada wlas to
check out for two months free on all
annual plans and I will see you in the
membrane segmentum right when I am back
[Music]
foreign